- I mean, just it doesn't match up.
The evidence is pointing
against what she's saying.
I've gotten requests from my friends,
family members, patients,
and everyone in between
to discuss this plandemic.
I usually try and make my
videos on the shorter side,
but I want to take this one point by point
to give you the clearest picture
of what my thoughts are
on this, as a doctor.
- Dr. Judy Mikovits has been called
one of the most accomplished
scientist of our generation.
So you made a discovery that conflicted
with the agreed upon narrative.
- Correct.
- [Host] Quick note, before we start,
the focus of my review here
will be based on science and facts.
For the sake of education,
there's very little value
in speculating on stories and claims
that cannot be verified.
I am a doctor and not a detective,
and I don't want to turn this
into a character assassination.
- If we don't stop this now,
we can not only forget our
republic and our freedom,
but we can forget humanity
because we'll be killed
by this agenda.
- The man who is heading
the Pandemic Task Force
was involved in a cover up.
- He directed the cover up.
And in fact, everybody else was paid off.
- I just want to look at the facts.
And so far very few facts
have been presented.
When you repeat this
phrase, I feel like a lot,
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence.
- What he's saying is absolute propaganda,
and the same kind of propaganda
that he's perpetrated
to kill millions since 1984.
That virus was spread through
because of the arrogance
of a group of people
and includes Robert Redfield,
who's now the head of the CDC.
They were working together to take credit
and make money and they
had the patents on it,
and tailored them to IL-2 therapy,
which was absolutely the wrong therapy.
And had that not happened,
millions wouldn't have died from HIV.
- When I first saw that, I was moved.
I was like, wait, can it be
possible that these doctors,
these researchers for major
government organizations
are making millions of dollars
at the expense of
millions of people dying?
So I looked into it, and
I stumbled upon an article
in the British Medical Journal,
which is a highly, highly
respected medical journal.
"The press agency reported
the two leading researchers
"Anthony Fauci head of the NIAID,
"and his deputy Clifford
Lane received payments
"relating to their development of IL-2
"as a treatment for HIV/AIDS.
"Dr. Lane told the BMJ that the payment
"was part of his federal compensation.
"He explained that the government
"patented the development
and share the payments
"it received with the inventors.
"Since 1997 he has
received about $45,000."
She's saying that Clifford
Lane, the deputy of the NIAID
and Dr. Fauci did this for $45,000?
To forego your creed to protect people
and instead to watch millions die?
"Dr. Anthony Fauci told the BMJ
"that as a government employee,
"he was required by law to
put his name on the patent
"for the development of IL-2
and was also required by law
"to receive a part of the payment
"the government received
for use of the patent.
"He said that he felt it was inappropriate
"to receive payment and donated
"the entire amount to charity."
If she wants me to believe
the claim she's making here,
she needs to disprove this.
- This is one of the things
that I've been saying
and would like to say to President Trump,
repeal the Bayh-Dole Act.
That Act gave government workers
the right to patent their discoveries,
so to claim intellectual
property for discoveries
that the taxpayer paid for.
Ever since that happened
in the early '80s,
it destroyed science.
- The Bayh-Dole Act, was
an Act that was passed
with bipartisan support both Democrats
and Republican support it
because they saw the value in it.
Initially, the way scientific research
was funded by the federal government,
would be they would give money
to a research institution,
and whatever that research
institution found,
the government would own the patent to it.
Now, in theory, this is great,
because the government
would own that patent,
and then if they wanted
to use it or sell it,
all the money would come
back to the taxpayers.
But in practice, it's not what happened.
What actually happened was,
the government collected
all these patents, and then 95%
of them sat collecting dust,
making no money for the taxpayers,
and no scientific
revolution was happening.
So now after Bayh-Dole,
what's happening is,
Harvard gets a small
grant for the government,
less than $3 million usually.
They find some kind of interesting piece
of preliminary research, they patent it,
and then they license it
out to private companies
who invest heavily in the promise
of getting one of these drugs
and making money in the future.
And from that, scientific
innovation flourishes.
And as a side benefit, the
taxpayers make more money.
Because of this Bayh-Dole Act,
we've brought a trillion
dollars into our economy,
which is then taxed and brought
back to us, as taxpayers.
It's also created something
like four million jobs
and over 11,000 startups.
And it also has a march-in
clause, that let's say,
the government gave a two
million dollar grant to Harvard.
They then patent whatever
research they found,
they license it to a
pharmaceutical company.
Now the pharmaceutical company
creates a drug or vaccine
and starts charging obscene
amounts of money for it,
or fails to actually put it out
'cause the company goes out of business.
Well, guess what?
There's a clause in this Act
that allows the federal
government to step in
and take over that patent.
All in all, this public-private
sector collaboration
is what makes innovation thrive.
And if you take one part
of that equation out,
the whole system crumbles.
If you let the government
run the system completely,
there's not enough innovation.
If you let the private
sector run it completely,
too much price gouging,
not enough competition.
You need to have that healthy balance.
Now, this doesn't mean that
pharmaceutical companies
are all good and we should not police them
or there's not shady things that happen.
Oh my god, do shady things happen.
But this Bayh-Dole Act is not the problem.
- And this is the crime behind
letting somebody like Bill
Gates with billions of dollars,
nobody elected him, he
has no medical background,
he has no expertise but
we let people like that
have a voice in this country
while we destroy the lives
of millions of people.
- Bill Gates is one of the
greatest philanthropic figures
of our time, if not the biggest donor.
Should we let Bill Gates
guide our medical decisions?
No, you're right he has
no medical expertise.
It's not for him to guide
our medical decisions.
But if scientists come to
Bill Gates asking for money,
he's able to choose who
he wants to donate to.
He does not make money from this.
In fact, last I heard the Gates Foundation
was running 70 clinical trials
to create a coronavirus
vaccine that they said
that they would not make money on,
they would not patent any of
it so that the general public
can have access to it at low cost.
This is amazing, actually
the USA Today even came out
and debunked the theory that
one of the Gates Foundation
subsidiaries could have had a patent
on something related to
coronavirus, it just wasn't true.
Unless you show me evidence
of the Gates Foundation
profiting from this,
everything you're saying
is just your thoughts.
And while your thoughts are great,
they mean nothing without facts.
- If we activate mandatory
vaccines globally,
I imagine these people stand to make
hundreds of billions of dollars.
- I'm not sure who he
means, "these people"
that are going to stand to make
hundreds of billions of dollars.
First of all, if the Bill Gates Foundation
actually finds the coronavirus vaccine,
and it's the one that's used,
they already said they're
not going to patent it,
they're going to make it free.
So that's already untrue there.
It's also important at
home for you to know
that anytime the federal government
puts out a recommendation for a vaccine,
it's automatically by law
covered by your insurance company
to the point that you have
zero out-of-pocket expenses.
- Are you anti-vaccine?
- Oh, absolutely not.
In fact, vaccine is immune therapy.
Just like interferon
alpha is immune therapy.
So I'm not anti vaccine.
- It's interesting, she
says she's not anti vaccine,
her book has a foreword in
it by Robert F. Kennedy,
who's one of the leading
anti-vax movement individuals.
And from what I read about the background
of this documentary, it was
funded by a lot of folks
who are part of what's known
as the anti-vaccine community.
Why would you want to be involved
with this documentary if you know that?
That's like being horribly
against the pharmaceutical
industry, and then taking money
for pharma to be in a commercial?
- Do you believe that this virus
was created in the laboratory?
- I wouldn't use the word created.
But you can't say naturally occurring
if it was by way of the laboratory.
- Again, this is her
giving her expert opinion
that she believes that
it was done in the lab.
I've seen other experts say that
they believe that it could
totally have come from nature
and jumped from animal
species to human species.
I also don't think that
point is really important,
'cause there's never been any evidence
to say that this was deliberate.
In fact, if it was deliberate,
this would be the worst ploy of all time.
It's the show in the world
economy affecting everyone.
- And do you have any ideas
of where this occurred?
- Oh, yeah, I'm sure it occurred
between the North Carolina laboratories,
Fort Dietrich, US Army Research Institute
of Infectious Disease,
and the Wuhan laboratory.
- How can you be sure?
There's so many virologists
who have the same specialty as you
that say that it could have easily come
from a specific animal species
and the jump to humans.
And then you're sure that it happened
between these laboratories.
I think even scientists
should be comfortable
with the unknown or the
fact that they may be wrong.
- [Reporter] $3.7 million flowed
from the National Institutes of Health
here in the US to the Wuhan lab in China,
the same lab where many people have said
that this coronavirus
infection first originated.
- The United States gives
grants all the time.
In fact, when you're talking
about research on viruses,
it takes an international
collaboration for that to work.
Because we know very well that anytime
you have a virus outbreak that
can spread in one country,
it's gonna end up in another country
if the virus has any kind
of infectivity at all.
That's why it becomes a pandemic.
So we have to be collaborative
and give research grants
and study each other's research.
That's part of it, that doesn't show
any kind of maliciousness
or negative intent.
- If my husband were to die, who has COPD,
his lungs have fibrosis,
his lungs would look
exactly like somebody with
COVID-19 theoretically,
but he has no evidence of infection.
So if you're not testing
and you don't have evidence of infection,
and if you walked in
there today, you know,
they'd call it COVID-19.
- If you're coming in for a broken leg,
and your leg gets infected,
and you end up dying from that infection,
we won't just put COVID-19
on your death certificate.
If you had COVID-19, you were
screened and tested for it
and you came positive, we would.
That would be counted in the death toll.
And you may think that's
unfair, that's inaccurate,
it may increase the numbers.
All we have to do is
look at overall mortality
for the last few years in
a place like New York City,
and you'll see that every
wintertime mortality spikes,
but if you look at the spike for 2020,
it's outrageous how many
more people have died.
You may be upset about the
way we're categorizing them,
COVID related, not COVID
related, COVID presumed,
but more people are dying,
and the only thing that
changed is COVID-19.
In fact, more people are staying home now
because of social distancing,
meaning that less trauma,
less car accidents, but
the deaths skyrocketed.
- When I'm writing up my death report,
I'm being pressured to
add COVID, why is that?
Why are we being pressured to add COVID
to maybe increase the numbers
and make it look a little
bit worse than it is?
- No one's being pressured, the
CDC puts out recommendations
of how you decide what
someone has passed from.
And you're free to follow
those recommendations or not.
As a practicing physician,
I've filled out death certificates.
When I was a resident, I
would do death pronouncements
all the time and there
are things that you write
that contributed to a person's demise.
For example, if someone had kidney cancer,
and it was an end-stage kidney cancer,
and while they were
dying from kidney cancer,
they got a pneumonia on top of that,
I would put both on the death certificate.
I can't say exactly which
one is the reason they died,
'cause you can't just say one thing.
So yes, if someone has a heart attack,
but they're also having a COVID infection,
it's very reasonable to put
both on the death certificate
and count it towards the COVID death toll.
Now, whether or not you think
this would create misinformation,
that's your choice.
But again, look at the amount
of people that have died
in comparison to the last 10 years.
The numbers have skyrocketed,
and it's simply because
of this COVID outbreak.
- I've talked with
doctors who have admitted
that they are being
incentivized to list patients
that are sick or have died with COVID-19.
- Yeah, $13,000 from Medicare,
if you call it COVID-19.
- [Reporter] Right now,
Medicare has determined
that if you have a COVID-19
admission to the hospital,
you'll get paid $13,000.
If that COVID-19 patient
goes on a ventilator,
you get $39,000, three times as much.
- The $13,000 and the
$39,000 figure are accurate.
This is how hospitals are
reimbursed for COVID-19 patients.
Now, while it sounds like
they're getting paid more
to diagnose more, the reality of the fact
is these types of bundled
payments actually save us money.
Let me explain, before these
types of bundled payments,
the way hospitals would
bill insurance companies
for treatment would be to say,
we did this, we gave these medications,
the patient stayed this long,
these are the doctors they saw,
these are the skilled technicians
that took care of them
and they would bill
for all these services.
And what we found was, they
were just wasting a lot of money
and not delivering great care.
So what CMS did was they said,
"Let's take an average in an area,
"of how much hospitals are spending
"on a typical pneumonia
case, on a heart attack case,
"and make it a standardized payment
"that then the hospital
has to make do with
"in treating the patient."
And what came out of that?
Well, the hospitals became more effective.
They said, we need to
be more cost effective,
and we need to deliver better quality care
to get patients better
sooner, so they can leave
and we can save some of that extra money
for ourselves as a profit.
The reason why we're paid $13,000
is 'cause we're spending time, resources,
medications, on that patient.
And on average, it costs
$13,000 to deliver that care.
In some areas, maybe it
will cost less than that,
and therefore you're
left with more profit.
In other cases, it gets really complicated
and it costs a lot more than
that and you lose money.
But on average, it should
cost around $13,000,
that's the fair rate set by CMS.
Again, this is very
effective both in terms of
cost-saving measures and patient outcomes.
Now the $39,000 figure for ventilators.
It's not like hospitals are
getting a three times bonus
by putting someone on a ventilator.
Ventilators cost money,
respiratory therapists
need to get billed for their time.
If a patient is put on a ventilator,
they need to be sedated
with expensive medications.
They need to be put into the ICU.
The reason hospitals
are being paid $39,000
is because it costs more to
deliver that level of care.
It's not 'cause now the
hospitals getting rich
by putting someone on a ventilator.
The hospital's actually incentivized
to deliver just enough care
in order to get the most money out of it
but at the same time,
get the patient better
as soon as possible.
- The patients I'm seeing in front of me,
the lungs I'm trying to improve,
have led me to believe
that we are operating
under a medical paradigm that is untrue.
And I fear that this misguided treatment
will lead to a tremendous amount of harm
to a great number of people
in a very short time.
- When used improperly,
ventilators can cause lung injury.
This is a well known phenomenon.
However, when you have a
new condition like COVID-19,
which we've never seen before,
we try and do our best
and adapt to the situation
as quickly as possible.
Does that mean we're going to be perfect
and we're not going to make mistakes
and patients aren't going to suffer?
Absolutely not.
Whether you're an ICU doctor
or a family medicine doctor,
nephrologist, you have protocols
that you're used to seeing,
patient comes in with condition X,
you know treatment for that is Y,
you need to order blood tests A, B and C
to monitor their progress and
you follow these protocols
that you've learned over your lifetime.
And you know how to adapt.
But with COVID-19, we're
seeing really unique cases
that we've just never seen described
in medical literature before.
So we're trying to learn very quickly,
but in this process, unfortunately,
patients have lost their lives.
This is not because we're
actively trying to harm patients.
This is simply because we're facing
an unprecedented pandemic
with a viral condition
that is new to us.
- I wanna know why Italy was hit so hard.
- Italy has a very old population.
- True.
- They're very sick with
inflammatory disorders.
They got it the beginning
of 2019, an untested,
new form of influenza vaccine
that had four different
strains of influenza,
including the highly pathogenic H1N1.
- Flu shots carry multiple
strains of the influenza virus.
We do that to increase the probability
of the vaccine being successful,
because we have to actually
predict the strains
that are going to be
circulating that season.
It's very difficult and
that's why the flu shot
is almost never 100% effective.
It usually carries an
effectiveness rate of 40% to 60%
depending on which viruses are out
and how well we predicted them.
- That vaccine was grown in a cell line,
a dog cell line, dogs
have lots of coronaviruses
and that's why they're not testing there.
- She said that because this
flu virus came from cells
of dogs and dogs have coronaviruses,
therefore, these people have coronaviruses
therefore they're not being tested.
Honestly just it's a
purely illogical statement,
like there's no other way to put that.
Humans have coronaviruses.
In fact, if you ever had the common cold,
the odds are once in your life,
it was caused by coronavirus.
The two most common viruses
causing the common cold
are the rhinovirus followed
by the coronavirus.
She's taking things that
are happening simultaneously
and connecting them
without any kind of proof
of this causation.
Experts are allowed to have theories
and a lot of these theories
will be proven to be incorrect.
That's part of the scientific process.
But you have to approach
this with a level of humility
by knowing that anytime
you're putting out a theory
it could be wrong.
And I don't feel like
she's doing that here
by acting as if what she's
saying is 100% accurate,
with no evidence to back it up.
- [Reporter] One question remains,
what happened to all
but hydroxychloroquine?
- We know that hydrochloroquine and zinc.
- This gentleman here is a chiropractor,
not a medical doctor, not
osteopathic physician.
- Are working great for patients.
And then Fauci comes out says,
"Well, there's no double blind
controlled placebo study,"
which, by the way, Dr.
Fauci is there going to be
a double blind controlled
placebo study of your vaccine?
- I've actually watched that entire clip
of him giving advice to patients.
And as part of that advice, he recommended
that if anyone has symptoms
related to COVID-19,
they should go out and get tonic water.
He knows that there is
quinine in tonic water,
which is also an anti-malaria drug,
similar but not exactly the
same as hydroxychloroquine.
And he believes that it would
help you if you have COVID-19.
However, what are chiropractor friend here
fails to understand is that the FDA
limits the amount of
quinine in tonic water
to about 83 milligrams, which means
you're gonna need to be drinking
12 liters of tonic water
every eight hours.
This is what happens
when someone doesn't have
a total grasp of scientific research,
starts making recommendations.
The fact that they used
him in this documentary
shows, to me at least,
that they don't care
who their sources are, they
don't even check for accuracy.
- [Reporter] In a survey
polling nearly 2300 doctors
in some 30 countries
hydroxychloroquine was ranked
as the most effective
medication to treat the virus.
- That was a really weird survey.
It literally asked
doctors, "What do you think
"is the front runner
for treating COVID-19?"
And doctors voted because, you know,
they estimated which medicine they thought
was gonna be best.
And they said hydroxychloroquine
and it doesn't mean
that that means it works.
You need randomized controlled
studies to make that happen.
However, let me not get
ahead of myself here.
We are using hydroxychloroquine
in our hospitals.
We are giving it to patients,
those who are admitted,
those who are not doing
well with COVID-19,
who are on ventilators, life support,
cannot wait for randomized
controlled studies.
The FDA said in this
situation, we can use an EUA,
which is an Emergency Use Authorization
to prescribe hydroxychloroquine
for our patients.
And honestly, our results
thus far don't look great,
'cause patients are still dying,
taking hydroxychloroquine.
And the reason why the
AMA stepped in and said,
"Hey, doctors stop prescribing this,"
was because the day after
President Trump announced that
he thought this could be
a potential game changer,
again, someone that's not a medical expert
giving their opinion.
The doses prescribed if it skyrocketed,
and then there became not
enough of the medication
for people who needed
it for its legitimate
FDA approved uses like
malaria, rheumatoid arthritis,
other autoimmune conditions.
- The AMA was saying, doctors
will lose their license
if they use hydroxychloroquine,
the anti-malarial drug
that's been on the list
of essential medicine
worldwide for 70 years.
Dr. Fauci calls that--
- Anecdotal data.
- Dr. Fauci does not
call hydroxychloroquine
a medication that's
based on anecdotal data.
Hydroxychloroquine is absolutely
an FDA approved medication
for several conditions, malaria,
rheumatoid arthritis,
autoimmune conditions.
And the AMA has never
said that if you use it
for these approved uses,
you will lose your license.
That is utter nonsense.
What they said was, if you start using it
for unapproved reasons,
like for the potential
that it may help with COVID-19
in patients who don't yet need
this medication desperately,
you are committing malpractice.
And that's a very reasonable
approach to take, why?
Because the only people
who should be taking
hydroxychloroquine before we have
randomized controlled studies
to prove its effectiveness and safety
are the people who can't
wait for those studies,
and who are ill now.
Otherwise, you're just putting
the general public at risk
and depleting our stockpiles
of this medication
for patients who need it
for their conditions now.
- It's not storytelling if
we have thousands of pages
of data saying it's effective
against these families of viruses.
- These thousands of
pages she's talking about
happen in animal models in
lab models, not in humans.
We've never compared it to
a control group properly.
So because of that, we cannot state
that it's approved for use.
We cannot state that it's
safe to use in this condition.
- There was an old antiviral
drug, 100-year-old drug
called Suramin on the WHO
list of essential medicine.
It literally gave kids with
autism a voice, a life.
What did Bayer and Monsanto do?
They took it away from everybody,
you couldn't get it to save
your life right now, we try.
- If a company, a pharmaceutical company,
had a medicine that worked for autism,
why in the world would
they give up those profits
and shelf that medicine?
It's not like they're doing it
in lieu of another treatment
that's going to make them more money.
We don't have a medication for autism.
Like it just doesn't make
sense to me, what she's saying.
- Is it safe to say that
anything that cannot be patented,
has been shut down intentionally
because there's no way to profit from it
all these natural remedies
that we've had for ever?
- Absolutely, that's fair to say.
- If we had all of these
natural remedies forever,
why was there disease before
the pharmaceutical industry
if we had all these natural remedies?
Short answer is we didn't.
Before antibiotics we suffered,
before vaccines we suffered.
With the invention of
antibiotics, vaccines,
we've drastically increased
length of life in the world.
To say that natural remedies
could have done all that
is purely inaccurate, it
just it's very inaccurate.
I will say though, that there
is a financial component
involved in medical research,
unless pharmaceutical companies
stand to make money from a product,
they will not research
it, generally speaking.
So you have to find ways
to incentivize them.
So I do think that in the world,
there exists certain products,
that because there's not a lot of money
to be made from them,
they've been largely ignored.
That's not the same as saying
what this gentleman just said
that they've been intentionally shut down.
I don't think that's happening
and I haven't seen evidence for it,
especially in this documentary.
- The game is to prevent the therapies
till everyone is infected,
and push the vaccines
knowing that the flu
vaccines increase the odds
by 36% of getting COVID-19.
- She said the idea is to
push all the therapies aside
so that everyone can get infected
and then we get a vaccine.
Dr. Fauci came on my YouTube channel
and said very clearly
that it it is his belief
and the general consensus of experts
that if you get sick with COVID-19,
you are most likely going to be immune
from getting it again?
- I would be willing to
bet on my experience,
and I'll bet your experience
that any virus that you have,
if you do well recover
and clear the virus,
if it acts like any other virus,
you're gonna have lasting immunity.
- So if everyone is infected with it,
why would we need a vaccine?
It doesn't make sense,
we don't want people infected with it.
Here, the government is
saying please stay home
so this virus doesn't spread.
And she says no, no, the government
wants everyone to get sick
that's why they're not letting
hydroxychloroquine be used.
You can't have it both ways.
- And push the vaccines
knowing that the flu vaccines
increase the odds by
36% of getting COVID-19.
- Where does that data come from?
- A publication last
year where the military
who had been vaccinated with influenza
were more susceptible to coronaviruses.
- The authors of this study
actually would disagree
with Dr. Judy here because
what they found was
by getting influenza vaccine,
participants were less
likely to get influenza.
They were also less likely to
get other types of viruses,
in general, when you look
at all the viruses that they could get.
What they did see was
some natural variation.
Most of the viruses went
down, some went slightly up,
one of the viruses that
went up were coronaviruses.
This is a type of natural variation.
You can't say that the influenza vaccine
caused those coronaviruses to occur.
And on top of it, the simplest
thing here that was missed
is that those coronaviruses
are not the coronavirus of
today, they're not SARS-Cov-2,
they're not the coronaviruses
that cause COVID-19.
Just because they're from the same family
doesn't mean they'll
behave in the same way.
There's just a lot of fundamental errors
in the way that she explains this.
- Coronaviruses are in every animal.
So if you've ever had a flu vaccine,
you were injected with coronaviruses.
- The fact that she said
if you had a flu vaccine,
you were injected with coronavirus
is horribly inaccurate.
- Our immune system is used to touching.
We share bacteria staphylococcus,
streptococcal bacteria, viruses.
We develop an immune
response daily to this stuff.
When you take that away from
me, my immune system drops.
As I shelter-in-place,
my immune system drops.
- What this doctor is talking about
is something called the hygienic theory.
And this hygienic theory is
actually the exact opposite
of what this doctor saying.
When you overly protect yourself,
you boil your children's water,
you don't allow them to play in the dirt,
you're constantly disinfecting
everything and anything that you touch,
you're not exposed enough
to viruses and bacterias,
so your immune system actually goes up,
not drops, and it actually goes up
to the point where it starts
overreacting to non threats.
And as a result, we've seen increases
in autoimmune conditions, in allergies
because we don't have
those bacterias and viruses
that we need to be exposed to.
So he's right but he there's
a misunderstanding there.
It actually increases your immune system
or over boosts your immune system.
There's a similar theory in
allergenic foods for children.
Before we used to not
give children peanuts.
And as a result, so many of
them developed peanut allergies.
But what we saw through medical research,
we gave children peanuts early
on, they were exposed to it,
therefore, they didn't
develop the allergies,
which is an overreaction
of the immune system.
So yes, you need to be exposed to viruses,
bacteria in order to be healthy
and for your immune system
to function optimally.
Completely agree with that.
But now, during a pandemic,
when you need to shelter-in-place
for a period of six to eight weeks,
that is not gonna harm your immune system,
either up or down to the point
where it's gonna destroy your flora
and now you can protect
yourself from illness.
If that was the case, we would
just not survive as humans
as long as we have.
We can easily adapt to
these circumstances,
especially because even
if we don't go outside,
we're covered in bacteria.
Millions and trillions of
bacteria are on an inside of us.
It is part of our natural flora.
And just because we may
not be going outside a lot,
we still go to the grocery
store, we walk our dogs,
we spend a little time in the park,
that is more than enough of
exposure to bacteria and viruses
that your body needs in
order to function optimally.
- And then as we all come
out of shelter-in-place
with a lower immune
system and start trading
viruses and bacteria, what
do you think is gonna happen?
Disease is gonna spike.
- What will happen and
I'm very confident of this
about disease going up once
this pandemic comes to an end,
those who were having
symptoms of some kind of
medical condition and didn't go get care
'cause they were worried about
getting sick with COVID-19
are then going to present to the hospital
with much more advanced cases.
Which is why on my YouTube
channel, on television,
I've been telling patients,
if there's something you're
concerned about your body,
do not hesitate to call
your family medicine doctor,
to visit a hospital, why?
Because there's other options available.
You can do a virtual visit,
you can come in through an isolation exit
where you're not gonna
get exposed to COVID-19.
And the reason why we
ask patients to stay away
initially during this pandemic,
was so we can make the hospital
safe place for everyone.
- Wearing the mask literally
activates your own virus.
- "Wearing the mask actually
activates your own virus."
I can't even begin to
process what that means.
Wearing the mask does not protect you,
wearing the mask protects
your respiratory droplets
from entering the environment
getting other sick.
And you may say yourself,
"Well, I'm not sick,
"I don't look sick."
Well, yeah, we've seen a lot of people
who don't show symptoms actually
be spreading this virus.
That's why it's been so tricky,
that's why it's so different from the flu.
- They've done such a great
job at manipulating the masses,
that it's other people
shutting down other citizens
and the big tech platforms follow suit
and they shut everything down.
There is no dissenting
voices allowed anymore
in this free country.
- They're dissenting voices,
and I'm hearing them right now
and no one's arresting
them for saying this.
That is the definition of free speech.
Whether or not a company wants
to put you on their server
is not free speech, it's
about public free speech.
You're allowed to go say
and hold any belief you want
as long as it's not putting
the public in danger.
I think we face a really
difficult situation
in talking about
takedowns on social media.
For example, the two urgent-care doctors
that were shown earlier in this clip,
their video was taken down from YouTube.
It's really, it's a fine line.
Because I'm a firm believer of putting out
accurate information to
combat misinformation.
And I'm a firm believer
that we need to listen
to dissenting opinions,
until they get to the point
where they become dangerous and or absurd.
I guess when I say absurd,
I think about Alex Jones.
- I'll admit it, I will eat my neighbors.
- I think YouTube or any
other social media platform
should feel very free to
take that content down.
Now, whether or not we
should take content down
of doctors we disagree with,
I think it's difficult.
I think in a situation like this
where we're in a pandemic,
there's evolving medical info,
doctors are allowed to
have different opinions.
I think that unless someone is
directly advocating for harm,
like eating Tide Pods or something,
I think only then should
you be taking down content.
- And I'm blown away why
they're not more doctors like me
talking about this all over the place.
We should be banding together right now.
You need to wake up because your liberties
are getting taken away from you
all because of fake news.
- I don't know what freedoms
are being taken away from him.
We're recommending people to
socially distance themselves
and enforcing that to
protect the general public
and doctors are coming together.
In fact, I did a video
interviewing 100 doctors
sharing their journeys, and
how different we all are.
But at the same time, we're
so unified in our message
about getting people to stay home,
about why it's going to
break our hospital system.
In fact, I would love to
invite this chiropractor
to come into a hospital setting
and see where patients are
being treated for COVID-19
so he understands why the
social distancing is a must,
at least for the short
term, until we figure out
what's what and then we could
start reopening America,
strategically, smartly, and safely.
- It's not the scientists
who are in any way dishonest.
They're listening to people
who for more than 40 years
have controlled, who gets
funded, what gets published.
And I'm sorry to say many, many people
will simply take the money
and the fame and that support,
things that absolutely aren't true.
- Are people betraying their ethics
and going for the money at times?
Absolutely, absolutely.
I'm not one of those people that believes
everyone just wants to do
things for the greater good.
No, no, people need to be incentivized.
And sometimes they make the wrong choices
and let money guide them
instead of what their initial goals were,
or at least maybe their initial
goals were always money.
That's not a formula for success, A.
And B, I don't think it's representative
of the medical community as a whole.
The huge majority of medical
professionals, nurses,
doctors, paramedics,
pharmacists, they went into this
to help people, they did not go into this
to make a killing financially.
There's other ways to make
money where you don't have
to go through horrendous
hours of education
and training for over
a decade of your life
in order to make a decent living,
after getting hundreds of
thousands of dollars in loans.
- You don't get funded, if you
don't speak the party line,
you don't get published, that
was probably the hardest thing
for me to take, is understanding
that scientific journals would
would twist the discovery
that should have healed all.
- Do I think that if
you have a radical idea
in the medical community,
initially, you'll be ostracized?
Yes, I think that's part of the process.
If you look at any of the people
that have made revolutionary
discoveries in science,
we're always looked at with a
lot of skepticism, initially.
But you have to approach new ideas
with a level of healthy skepticism.
Otherwise, you'll just believe
a lot of inaccurate information.
And it's a very difficult job of agencies
like the NIH, CDC, WHO, to decide
which theories they should test.
- So what we did pretty much
ever since I got out of jail,
we started an education company.
We wake up doctors, and
it's very difficult.
But every doctor who realized
they may have been part of the problem
has now turned that around to march
toward a better society and restore faith
in the promise of medicine.
- I can sit all day and
talk about the things
that are wrong with medicine.
But as a whole, we're helping people,
we're eradicating
diseases, we're decreasing
the strain on our healthcare
system of COVID-19
by treating patients, by finding vaccines.
To say that the entire system is a fraud,
because she believes it to be
without any kind of research
to say that it is,
I think it's a failure on her
part more than it is ours.
I want to leave off with a
message to my fellow doctors
and medical professionals out there.
I think we need to do a better job
with our scientific communication,
of how we talk to people,
we should not resort
to heavy data, sarcasm,
or even take downs,
in order to silence this
type of information.
Allow dissenting opinions to be heard,
confront them, correct them
and put the accurate
medical info out there
so people can make the
decisions for themselves.
Also know that I'm not the only
doctor sharing this message.
Here's actually a video of 100
doctors that I've interviewed
talking about their battle with COVID-19.
(soft music)